[inaudible].
All right. So let's shift to your
new book, living with the monks.
I want to get the, the subtitle
totally right here cause I love it.
What turning off my phone
taught me about happiness,
gratitude and focus. So we
are taping this right now. Uh,
we're holding it for a little bit because
I want to air this right before I go
off the grid because my audience knows
I do this August off the grid thing.
Literally lock my phone in his safe.
No phone, no TV, no electronics,
no nothing.
I'm going to work on my book a little bit.
I'll probably escape to
a beach for a little bit.
I'm not even totally sure
what I'm going to do,
but just get off the
endless information grid.
So before we talk about me and
why I think it's good to do that.
What led you to wanting to
do this in the first place?
Well, I'd spent, I'd invested so much
in the physical side from my whole life,
you know,
running marathons and doing
endurance events and had a
navy seal move in with me.
But I really had felt like I had neglected
the inner side and just the inner
work and I was just going so fast.
So I felt too to really,
again, maybe I'm turning
all their, I don't know,
but to get the whole package or that
what I want and be as well rounded.
I really needed that side. There's
the spiritual side. And um,
and I was just thinking like,
well who would be the best teacher?
And I thought monks and I didn't know
anything about monks other than like
watching some movies, you know,
fringe articles here and there.
I thought that'd be really
cool to learn about, you know,
the traditions and how
amongst lived their lives.
And I'm doing exactly what
you said. You know, I'm,
I'm bombarded by information and
I don't spend any time alone.
And when you don't spend time alone,
you lose your super power,
use your intuition because you're being
influenced by everybody else and your
exercise, your gut muscle.
I was losing my superpower.
So I said to Sarah, I think
I want to go. And, and
was there a moment that you really felt
that you had lost it or that you could
really recognize that you lost it?
Because I think a lot of people walk
around with that all the time now.
I just felt just cause
the endless social media,
you're so hit with stuff
constantly that it does make your,
your sort of inner monologue
sort of harder to listen
to because it's just being
slammed in every way.
It was a buildup. I just felt so
distracted. Yeah. And you know,
we all feel overwhelmed. I mean, but I
felt really distracted and I felt like,
you know, I have four kids
a job, I'm married friends,
my parents are getting older.
I mean all these different things.
And then all these different social media
things and news and Netflix and Hulu
and the, a little bit about, I'm
like, I just want to, like, I got to,
I wouldn't be alone. And so
it was a buildup. And then we,
my wife and I were talking
about it as I just want to,
I'm going to go and live in a monastery.
And she was super encouraging, you know,
and she was like, um, so,
so that's what happened.
So what do you, do you give a call, you,
you to say, is this a
Yelp thing? Yeah. Uh,
yes. Siri. I, um,
I actually found this monastery through
a friend of mine who was actually my
publisher and a,
I went to a monastery with eight months,
which already was a misconception for
me cause I thought monastery meant
community meant hundreds,
but there were eight months at this
particular monastery for which had been
there for 50 years. Wow. And they
lived on 500 acres in the states,
but in isolation, 500 acres. And
similar to what you're about to do in,
in August or now, um, you
know, no phone, no Internet,
no news, no this, no that. Uh,
and I just took 15 days to decompress.
So what was it like?
So you get there day one, I mean,
what was the most shocking part?
I got sent to a pretty open guy.
So there was probably not much that can
shock you, but like what do they say?
Do they like take all your stuff? First
of all, they were Russian Orthodox.
They weren't Buddhists like that arrest.
I didn't,
I had no expectation of anything.
And um,
I walked into my room,
which they call cell, that's the
rooms are called sales and monastery.
And it was the size of this carpet,
like where we are. And I had a bed,
one little desk with a light
and brother, uh, Christopher,
who was like my Goto monk,
uh, sat me down and he said,
tomorrow at 7:00 AM we'll
start with prayer, reflect,
reflection and meditation. And
I said, okay, it's 6:00 PM,
you know, what do I do next? 13 hours.
And he looked at me and he said,
you think?
And I said,
okay.
And he left the room and I realized like,
I can't call my wife,
I can't, there's no books in my
room. I mean, they had books,
but there are no books. There's
no like, it's super like eerie,
quiet. Yeah. And I'm like, all right,
I'm going to, I'm going to meditate.
Let me start the journey. I took a
TM, transcendental meditation course,
set my timer for 20 minutes,
and I sat in my chair and I started to
close my eyes, focused on the mantra.
And, um, I'm getting bombarded on,
well, how am I kids, my wife, you know,
the hawks are going to be, what are
we going to do this shit, you know,
everything's going through my head and
I will talk about the hawks were window
by the way. I'm sitting and I'm going
and I'm like, why hasn't my beeper beep?
Cause I've been here forever. And
I'm like, I probably didn't start it.
So I let me just keep going, keep going.
And finally there's no beep. And I said,
well, let me just reset my beeper
and I'll start over. No, I go back.
That will be cheating anyway. I mean
my chair forever. And I finally like,
this is ridiculous. I'll just let
me reset this and start this again.
I opened up my eyes, I look at my time
or three minutes and 27 seconds. Wow.
And I am really calculated how many
minutes I have left on the monastery.
I did 15 days times 24 times.
And I was like,
I just said to myself,
I'm fucked. Like this is,
this is great on paper in theory,
but this is going to be fucking hard.
And I just sat in my room and I was like,
oh my God,
why did I get myself into where
you allowed to leave the room?
I can leave the room. Um, I
couldn't leave the property.
This is the craziest situation.
So the monks to keep the
lights on at the monastery,
they breed German shepherds.
So there are 11 adult German shepherds,
eight monks.
And so they're selling German shepherds.
Yes. They sell puppies. That's,
and they trained dogs. They're
world renown dog trainers. World's,
they've written books. They've sold
millions of copies of books. They're just,
it's just a really unusual scenarios.
So yes,
I could leave myself and walk around
the monastery, but first of all,
it's four degrees outside.
It's P, there's no lights.
It's like pitch dark at four o'clock.
It's freezing.
There's bear according to the monks like,
so no, I really couldn't leave them.
Right. So I mean I just kinda like, um,
I ended up walking 120 miles up and down
the driveway they had because I had to
get some exercise over the course of my
journey, but I didn't, I didn't leave. So,
um,
I just sat there and you know,
the first five to s five days was really,
really difficult for me.
And I started immediately doing
probably what I think most people do.
Certainly what I do,
I started giving myself an out.
I started justifying that it would
be okay to go home early jazz,
seven days, man, that's enough. Get out
of here in seven days. No one's gonna say,
Oh, you didn't do whatever. Just,
and I started creating all these excuses
in my head and I started thinking
myself like,
what are the goals do I have in areas
of my life and my giving excuses in,
you know,
and really started like analyze everything
that was going through my head and
put it into out the,
the real my real world.
And I just saw a lot of things
about myself, you know, through the,
through just being quiet and alone.
How did you break through that moment
of I can get away with seven days here.
Like what was the actual
thing that turned down on it?
I have a two words that changed my
life that I refer back to all the time.
And um, the, when I wanted to go
home, those two words were like,
I signed up 15 days.
That's what,
that's what this goal was 15 days.
Day five when I really want to go home
and I missed my kids and I couldn't call
them. You know, the two words are,
remember tomorrow when you have a big
split second decision or a big major
decision, how, how is that decision
going to make you feel tomorrow?
So I said to myself,
if I drop out and quit now the one
time I'm going to do this in my life,
how am I going to feel about this tomorrow
when I get home? When someone says,
how'd you do? Did you make
it terrible? You know, if I,
my legs are swollen at mile 18 I want to
drop out of the race. So the marathon,
but I don't want to come home. And the
next day after the New York Marathon,
did you finish?
So remember tomorrow.
So I just kind of said that
to myself over and over,
like just remember how you gonna feel
about this and remember how proud you are
going to feel at the end of the journey.
And before I went, my wife said,
don't leave until you have a
breakthrough. You're broken. And I'm like,
I'm not broken. And I haven't
had a breakthrough. I'm saying,
so did you get broken
or have a breakthrough?
You know, it's funny. I
have to, I know the answer,
at least the one I had some breakthroughs
for sure, but I never felt broken.
And I think,
I think the reason I never felt broken
is because it has a definitive end date.
Yeah.
So broken for you would have been like,
I'm leaving.
Okay. Would it be like, yeah. It would
have to really take me to a place of,
you know? Yeah. Yeah.
I mean I had moments of being broken
and Super Sad. I mean, you know,
like when you're away from everything
and you don't know what's going on,
you just don't know.
You don't know God on my kids getting
bullied or something happening is my wife.
Okay.
You know is the world in risk is you
just don't know and you start to imagine
that the world's going to end.
I think your brain automatically goes to
the words, it doesn't go to everything.
It's great. It's like, Oh shit,
I should've been so much nicer than
my wife because I'm going to go there.
She's not going to be
home when I get home.
Like you start sticking shit like that
and then it just spirals because you have
energy and space to think and imagine
and dream and envision and all the shit
that's like,
it all comes to the surface and you know,
cause it's in the real world.
If you're having a tough day,
you could say to Dave, you, you, you,
you guys were like, you know what?
Let's put on a movie and Netflix and
just so fucking escape. And you sit down,
you order Chinese food and you
have your Netflix and you watch it.
But guess what, the issues don't
go away when the movie's over.
That shit is still there.
Now your to do list.
They're still there when I'm
watching Netflix itself, right.
They're still there and you know,
this forced you, there was no escape.
This was your escape.
So it forced me to have to think through
stuff and I got a lot of clarity.
You know, it's funny, although
this is in no way comparable.
When I did my off the great thing
last year and half for a week,
we were at 10 days or so,
we were in Mexico and I just,
I just needed to do nothing.
I just needed to wake up every morning,
have a light breakfast. I went to the
gym and then I would just sit there.
I got the same seat at the beach every
day and I would just sit and stare at the
ocean for hours,
really for hours and I'd do all that,
try to do a little meditation and stuff.
Um,
but I did have that moment at
one point where I was like,
anything could be happening right now.
Like World War three could be starting
there, you know, terror attack. Like boom,
you know, Zombie, like where do
you go to like the craziest shit.
And then I remember thinking,
I was like, you know,
you go there for awhile and
then I suddenly got to the
end of it and I was like,
well nothing I could do about it
right now. So I better reset to this,
to this better place.
And there's a real discipline in that in,
in how you can control your
mind and your thoughts.
I think the F for sure for the first
three or four days there I was obsessed
with my to do list and by
day four or five I'm like,
if a hurricane came and whisked
my to do list into the ocean,
life goes on. Like I'll be
okay. Yeah. And you know, I was,
I was like a captive to my
to do list because you know,
I'm always, and it's
my to do list. For me.
It wasn't even about finishing the tasks
as good as I could possibly do them.
It was about finishing up so I can keep,
it felt so good to cross them off that
even if it was 70% to what I could
probably do it onto the next,
onto the next,
onto the next at the monastery. The
the, the most only had to do list.
There was no to do list.
It was whatever is in front
of me is my task at hand.
So tell me a little bit just
sort of what that day looks like.
So you get up the next morning,
now it's day two.
So Day seven did you say 7:00 AM or
6:00 AM 7:00 AM and then prayer starts?
Yeah, so they would ring a big, a
big like Notre Dame, Notre Dame.
We like Church and val loud.
I was right next to which was the,
which signals to go to the,
to the church where they,
we would have a bout an
hour and a half service,
which was meditation,
reflection service that w
was it religious in any way?
They were Russian Orthodox. It was,
it was a religion. It was religious.
For me it was, it was peaceful.
Um, but it was definitely,
it's definitely religious. And then,
and then we would shift to, um,
breakfast, which was traditionally
silent. Most of those breakfast,
the breakfasts were silent
and that would go to,
let's say nine 30 or 10 and afterwards,
that'd be a little bit of alone time.
And then it would go to tasks and each
of the monks would have a different
responsibility,
which was just unbelievably efficient.
And I spend each day shadowing a different
long, so I got two rounds basically.
Uh, and then there would be supper.
Dinner was lunch time, so they flip flop.
So breakfast was a really light meal,
which for me is just fruit. Then lunch,
their lunch was dinner.
That would be the big meal rest.
Or if like sleep away camp you go
less rest time we will see more labor,
which could be cleaning the church,
doing something,
whatever the everyone's tasks where,
yeah.
Did they always have stuff to do? Cause
I, it's, it's like, it's kind of funny,
like if you think about it, like, all
right, so eight guys living at this place,
you're always doing stuff always seems
like there wouldn't be that much more to
do.
You know,
she didn't want to know why,
if, if the toilet breaks,
they don't call a plumber to fix the
toilet. They built the monastery by hand.
They, everything is, they do
everything right. Well let's,
let's get a swimming
pool. Okay. Get a shovel.
You get a shovel and you get a shovel,
you know, let's figure out how to do it,
you know, and we'll build,
well, the swimming pool please.
So they do every hire you for a couple of
jobs. I didn't, I couldn't do anything.
I was a supervisor. Um, and then,
and then we would,
there was just more time alone.
So there was a tremendous amount of
time. Yeah. But also true. A lot of work.
So talk a little bit about the
disconnecting from technology.
I get the concerns about your
wife, your kids, things like that.
How did you feel about not putting your
hand in your pocket to go to your phone
or not having an iPad right in front of
you or television screen or the rest of
it?
You know, it's funny cause when
I got back, everybody asked me,
well what'd you miss?
And on the obvious answers I
missed my family and this and that,
but no one ever asked
me what didn't you miss?
And what I didn't notice at all were
things that I do everyday that I thought I
would miss. For example, I went
during the NCAA tournament.
I didn't miss not watching March madness.
It's been a pivot,
let's move suddenly I'm
loved to do forever.
And if I calculated how many hours of
basketball I've watched, it's like,
you know,
it's probably a years of my life,
but I didn't miss it and I didn't
miss hitting like that. You know,
liking my friend's picture and canned
cocoon with, with, with a corona.
I didn't miss any of that stuff.
I didn't miss going through Hulu and
Netflix and debating with my wife what to
watch. And I realized I spent a lot of
time on things that I really didn't miss.
And if I eliminated some of those,
I would freed up a lot more time to
spend to do the things I love to do with
people. I love to do them with. Yeah. So,
but it was so comfortable with
my phone's always in my hand.
It was hard, man, really hard. It took,
it took a long time to get past that.
Did you feel that there was like a
little bit of a learning curve with it?
Like when I did it and as I said,
I locked my phone in a safe,
I did not know the code and I found that
for the first day or two I kept going
in my pocket, even at the beach,
like I'm just going to be,
but there's nothing in my pocket.
I don't even think my shorts had pockets,
so I was just like going like this.
And then there's like this weird
anxiety of like, what's going on?
What did I miss? Is the Zombie apocalypse
or the war started or whatever.
And then suddenly by day like five,
I kind of felt empowered by day eight.
I was like,
I want nothing to do with that.
Then maybe there's a little bit of
like a return to a, it'll be okay,
I'll manage it differently.
Did you go through all of them
exempts the exact steps that you just
mentioned in the exact timeframe you just
did? Yeah. Um, once I got to the
point where I didn't miss it,
where the habit of checking before I
went to bed or waking up at five in the
morning and seeing anything new come
in through, you know, the words.
Once I got past that, yeah. Uh, I just,
I didn't miss it. I didn't want it,
you know? And once I got home and I
put on the news and read, you know,
like what's going on in the world and
all the negative stuff, it was just like,
ah, but here I am, I've been home and
then I'm back on my phone and I came home.
I'm like,
I'm off email.
Yeah. I'm all, I don't need. Right
Kevin, you know, but you drift back.
So have you been able to put any kind
of just personal policies in place to
manage this stuff? Cause
I'm, I'm still trying,
I don't do phone in
bedroom 90% of the nights.
Every now and again it just somehow ends
up there. But like that's one for me.
So that at 5:00 AM I just don't do that.
Yeah. And you know I've been the obvious
ones, you know. No, not in the bedroom.
Not at meal time.
Not In movies I'm at.
And I used to sit and movies and I
heard a ding or a beep or a buzz.
Yeah. I'd go into my shirt and look,
you know, it's like light, you know,
or look under here.
But now, so there's, so I, I became this,
I think this will summarize
my experience the best.
They had a retreat at the monastery and
they had all these guests and when the
guests left they said to me,
Jesse,
you are going to clean up all the dishes
like the, like the rookie on the team.
Okay,
there's 500 dishes stacked.
So I started cleaning the dishes and I'm
drawing them and cleaning up and drying
them and they'd go and they bring more
in and I turned to them, I'm like,
I'm just going to take me forever.
How am I going to do all of these dishes?
And one of the monks turned, he
goes, there's not all those dishes.
There's only the dish that's in your hand.
And I was like,
it reminded me that I'll never wear,
my feet are,
and I gotta be where my feet are,
you know, this is what I'm doing.
Yeah.
There's something there.
Because I do find that I
actually like doing the dishes.
I know that's a little nuts
and I'm not doing it for him.
I'm not doing it for 500 people.
But I do find it's like one of like,
I can't have my phone in my hand while
I'm doing the dishes. Right. Like I,
it's one little thing that
you're doing right there.
So I do find on these brief
moments that you, you know,
I'm on tour right now and
it's like when I'm doing this,
when I have these brief moments,
I like doing like very menial.
Like I really like gardening or just
like cleaning up outside or like these
things that aren't much
because they seem to have this,
this is incredible important.
We've lost touch with a lot of those
things that help us feel connected.
You know,
like we have no connection to our food.
We go to a supermarket, we have no,
unless you live on a farm,
like we're very disconnected from a lot
of things that make us tick and simple
things like that bring us back
down to earth and they ground us.
And I felt the same way
I felt as a contributor,
even if it's contributing to
your own household, you know?
And as opposed to having someone to come
and clean it or however you guys do it
or whatever. Um, but it makes you
feel connected, important part of it.
And uh,
it creates momentum and wins.
I can't explain it, but I felt
the same way. I love it. I was,
yeah. Yeah. There's real value in that.
Like even when you came into my
house and you're really like, oh,
it's so great here and this and
that. And it's like, I really love,
like we put a lot of effort into like I
want to like wake up in the place that I
want to be at and like make it better
and make it more valuable in all that.
So for the average person that can't
maybe go take a month to do this,
what's the piece of advice? Or is it,
can people do a weekend with monks?
Can you do it? Can you just do a day with
monks? Maybe. I think it was, and I think,
I think anyone could spend time alone.
Yeah.
I think spending time alone and you
reckon I recognize like I don't spend any
time alone other than going
for runs, which is, you know,
but I think it's really important because
I think the only way you can really be
in tune with your gut is to be,
is to spend some time alone.
So I think that's really important.
I think for me,
I carry a lot of stuff in my head.
I realized that I need to,
like I put everything on paper now I get
out of my head, it doesn't disappear,
but it frees up space.
I had a lot of space and creative energy
at the monastery because I didn't have,
I wasn't cluttered. So now I have
a two journal system that I use.
It's very simple. I dump everything
into one big journal. Doesn't go away,
but it's out of my head. Yeah.
I don't have to remember.
I could get a kid at birthday present or
whatever and then I make my daily kind
of routine and, and, and
this kind of thing. And um,
yeah.
And I think just being really aware of
where your feet are is really important.
I mean the monks from Mano taskers I live
in a world of multitasking and I think
that, you know, for the
everyday, for everybody,
I think that feels overwhelmed
or field feels distracted,
is to do one thing at a time
and do it well and move on.
Have you been back to the monastery since?
I'm going to go, I haven't been back.
What I plan on going to go back to
partake you get or is it just like,
can you go like have lunch with them like
just for some high fives and that like
they're down for that sort of thing.
Like I think the dad for some, yeah,
for some high five I guess you'll
find out. I mean I was like an alien.
I came here, there I was full
energy. I'm like, ugh. I'm like,
well what are we running?
Did it,
did they have any idea of your history
or just you know that your success is any
of that stuff. They just think
it's just some guy. Yeah, we're,
we're letting in on this.
I remember that must've been
pretty cool in and of itself.
I remember very clearly sitting down
and I was telling him about my journey.
I was talking about coconut water
and they all looked at me and said,
what's coconut water?
I was talking about the Atlanta Hawks
and one of them raised their hand, said,
I went to an expos game. Wow. In
Montreal. And I'm like, that's baseball.
Don't anymore. Like, you know. Yeah. All
right, well for our last few minutes left,
let's talk about the hawks for a second
and just, Oh, you own a basketball team,
which to me is, as you
know, I love basketball.
Like that's like the
greatest thing on earth.
Like I would probably stop doing all this.
I would trade it in to own a
basketball team. I'm, I'm, I'm,
I'm not the principal owner. I'm part of
the yeah. And uh, we got a great group,
but for me,
living in Atlanta as a basketball fan,
I was a season ticket holder for years
first and then I was a consultant to the
team,
so I got to fall in love with the players,
the coaching staff and management first
and now to be part of the ownership
group with my wife and friends.
It's a in a city that I live in.
Yeah. And a team that I love. Yeah.
It's like, you know, it's just,
it's just unbelievable. There's, I was
talking to my wife the other day, I said,
you know, from my father and my
family and my friends and the city,
there's 80 plus games a year where
I could put the tea nights a year,
I could put the TV on. I'm thinking
about you as a knick fan. Yeah.
Multiply it by 20. And just, you
know, as, and just really love it.
So it's been super exciting and I
think we've got a really bright future.
So I'm looking forward to
the next couple of years.
I know it was a little before
your time of owning the hawks,
but how has Dominique Wilkins
not in the hall of fame?
And I love Nick. How's that guy? Not
In the whole thing. He deserves to be,
he deserves to be. He's a, not
only is he great basketball player,
but he's in Atlanta. He's, you know, he's
just a big part of the, of the community.
So if he's still part of the, Oh, is
that right? And Yeah, he does the play,
but he's, um, is that every game? So I,
I never seen him say no to a
photo or an autograph ever.
Never just,
um,
he makes people feel really good and
uh, he's very approachable. Yeah.
What are you guys doing over there to just
bring all of the things that you've talked
about here into the game and make it
fun and add some of the other stuff
that's not part of the 48 minutes? Like,
you know,
the Goto hurts go thing.
I think there's several buckets.
There's the internal bucket and wrestlers,
the principal on.
He's done an amazing job of just,
we have a new practice facility
that's state of the art best,
probably one of the best in the
NBA. Uh, we're renovating the arena.
Massive multi hundred million dollar
rent of renovation that's going on now.
So there's a whole,
there's like the internal stuff and
then there's the game presentation.
There's so many layers,
game presentation.
There's the actual basketball side of it.
Um, there's the nights that, that, that,
that the team doesn't play, that the
arena is available. We have a concert.
I mean it's just,
there's so many layers of it,
but I think at the end of the day it's
that enthusiasm and passion and just
bringing whatever you can to
infuse a culture of thick,
of your emotional connection
to the next you taught.
First thing you said to me when I
walked in with you took me to 94 games.
Yeah. You remember those? I remember
where I was sitting for a certain games.
You know what you're eating
and you're 25 years ago. I don't remember
what I ate last week. Exempt. Right.
You'd have no idea.
There's just so much emotion.
And if we could bring that same passion
to the community and marry that with the
Atlanta Hawks, that's going to be super
powerful. And I think we can all run away.
What wasn't Mandy? It's
pretty clear you're bringing
that to your life every day.
Cause this was just, I mean this flew by
and it's like I could feel it on time.
That's it. That's it. Well you got to
go do Rogan now, so I don't want to,
I don't want to steal
all your brain power.
You got three more hours with Rogan I
sent to you are going to be up to it to
the challenge and don't even
drink caffeine. You just
hopped up on coconut water.
I am potassium doubt. You don't even
need bananas anymore. Do you have any,
why would he have been at this point?
I had a lot of it and just eat the bananas
too too. Well, listen, man, it's been,
it's been an absolute pleasure.
I suspect we will cross paths
again perhaps in Atlanta
because even though we're
holding this for a little bit, uh,
maybe a little bit, they come watch Ya.
All right. We're going to come to the
shore, the Peterson event in Atlanta.
Awesome. Uh, for more on Jesse,
you can check out Jesse itzler.com.